hallo mein name ist luke ist mein mikro
ja es läuft bei ihm merkt schon relativ
gut drauf weil ich heute meine letzte
klausur geschrieben habe verfügte
scheiße machen ich bin fertig wir
spielen heute das hanauer game
da geht es darum dass wir hier links den
feminismus eingeblendet haben und rechts
ägypten und wir müssen sagen was wird
wohl mehr gegoogelt
es wird ihn nichts mehr als krankhafter
scheiße gegoogelt ich würde einfach mal
sagen ägypten wird weniger oft gegoogelt
als der micha ok
das ist hammer ich komm zurück zum pc
gelaufen und see you score 0 samstag mal
live in in bonn scoreboard wird coffee
shop oder karate mehr gegoogelt ich
würde sagen karate wird öfter gegoogelt
als der coffeeshop genau gleich wieder
okay da kann ich jetzt nichts falsch
machen
chichén itzá ist das ein weltwunder
pizzaessen weltwunder
das weiß ich peter szyszka würde ich
sagen ist weniger als karate nämlich nur
246.000 mal dann haben wir als nächstes
jennifer lopez definitiv mehr das geht
schon in die millionen nämlich 3,35
millionen schon wieder was mit ägypten
und warum sind die frau die pyramiden
pyramiden auf jeden fall weniger
anstelle von lopez prison break
definitiv mehr dem besten serie aller
zeiten nach meinen videos
wer es eher den coups
wer ist denn muss ich bin nämlich sicher
aber ist muss der typ der dieses mal was
ich habe eine ukulele hast hier ist man
nicht cool eli aber das hatten hier
einen eine zuschauerin mal geschenkt und
damit sich jetzt langsam eroberte
rainbow
[Musik]
ihr wollt könnt ihr einfach mal lassen
und bei 40.000 gleichwertig den fall
komplett produzieren und auf meinem
kanal raushauen
jok
ich würde sagen er wird weniger als 2,24
millionen mal gegoogelt nämlich nur
22.000 mal okay dass man nicht mal ein
knappes drittel donald trump
ich will nichts falsches sagen als der
präsident ist donald trump wird
definitiv öfter gegoogelt nämlich die 3
[Musik]
was er wurde einfach 13 6 millionen mal
also wird er monatlich gegoogelt
ich hab übels hungermann alles klara da
auf jeden fall weniger ich glaub ich hab
noch nie was erlebt was so viel wie so
oft googelt wurde wie donald trump ich
schreib mal in die kommentare ich habe
das hier schon öfters hochgeladen was
war so das was glaube ich am meisten
bisher aufrufe hatte kenny rogers oft
jeden fall weniger als gerade dann haben
wir als nächstes the big bang theory das
geht auch in die millionen nämlich 1,2
millionen
hättest ja einerseits diese plattform
fotos hochgeladen werden und wo leute
reden halten und inspirationen und ihre
entwicklung vorstellen andererseits ist
natürlich auch ein bekannter vorname
andererseits ist es natürlich auch
beispielsweise dieser kinofilmen wo
diese leute einfach so viele drogen
nehmen deswegen würde ich sagen das hat
auch so um die fünf millionen also heyer
und das hat okay 1,5 millionen auf jeden
fall ist es hören manuel santos du
klingst wie eine spanische druck in buzz
definitiv weniger als 1,5 millionen
nämlich nur 40.000 dann haben wir hier
sangria oh mein gott definitiv mehr
donkey kong country okay okay wir donkey
kong öfter gegoogelt als sangria warum
stehe ich hier so als würde ich auf
einem surfbrett stehen ich kenne google
ich würde gern wissen ich habe gerade 13
punkte das heißt ich habe 13 mal dass in
hintereinander sag ich mal richtig
beantwortet deswegen will ich jetzt wenn
hier stets andrea gegen donkey kong
ich will jetzt keine falsche
entscheidung treffen man kann ja nicht
mal googeln nach der lösung weil es sind
ja die monatlichen sucht zahlen nicht
die insgesamten ich denke donkey kong
country hat weniger und zwar 47.000
74.000 shakira definitiv mehr das geht
auch in die millionen nämlich 2,7
millionen european junior
mutter vor ich würde dann weniger
der renault clio renault clio ich mag
das auto überhaupt nicht aber ich weiß
nicht ob es mehr oder weniger hatte ich
würde sagen weniger als die european
juni nämlich nur 550.000 dann haben wir
jetzt shirt oh mein gott dass das wird
ganz ganz eng ich würde sagen weniger
als renault clio wir sind nämlich bei
250.000 dann haben wir hier ramadan
ramadan hat der definitiv mehr nämlich
823.000 und dann haben wir mit my wife
were
denn noch mal mit referee heißt
geburtshilfe ja okay ist er auch schon
eingeblendet würde ich sagen hat weniger
als der ramadan nämlich 27.000 dann
haben wir hier django unchained wow
alter ich habe eines kopf und 20 gerade
deswegen
jetzt nicht verpacken ich sag mal
einfacher und zwar als 450.000 ok meine
damen und herren wir sind auf einem
guten weg hier wirklich wir haben schon
neuen highscore glaube ich
das ist meine
beste runde heyer games die ich je
gespielt habe bisher wenn ihr gerade am
handy sein oder wenn ihr am pc sagt ist
es scheißegal paktes wegschaut mein
video gern weiter an aber klatscht mal 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
20 21
weil ich schon so weit bin was ist das
hier für ein video war mich so
energiegeladen und plötzlich habe die
kompletten letzten vier tage täglich so
circa acht bis zehn stunden vor dem
laptop verbracht oder belehren oder
sachen ausgedruckt deswegen fühle ich
mich gerade so schön hier vor dem also
ich bin hässlich aber ich fühle mich
einfach geil ja also ich bin trotzdem
hässlich aber durch den bürgern deinen
kopf
ich finde es klasse dass ich hier gerade
einfach stehen kann von meinem pc kann
das aufnehmen und hat keine gedanken
gänge mehr zu verschwenden an klausuren
ey was ist los mit meinem leben ich weiß
gerade übels ich glaub so fühlen sich
normale youtube ist ob beruflich machen
jeden tag
thomas fox das hat glaube ich weniger
als django unchained und zwar 135000
dann haben wir 50 center geht auch in
die millionen nämlich 1,5 millionen
bobby moore hat weniger das ist eine
fußball-legende 49.000 lionel richie hat
mehr als 49.000 nämlich 550.000 six
nations hat meine ehe ich das hatte ich
schon mal da hatten die extrem viel ich
bin mir aber nicht sicher deswegen würde
ich sagen lauer als lionel richie
nämlich 165000 dann haben wir hier
serena williams liegt auch in die
millionen das ist eine sehr sehr gute
tennisspielerin der iran hat glaube ich
weniger als serena williams nämlich 1,2
millionen kam
wow
kammer
heute hat kam am meer oder hat der iran
mehr das ist doch das kann doch nicht
wahr sein was soll ich denn jetzt hier
machen dass ist doch die hauptsache ich
drück erstmal rechts klinkhammer luca
ich bin mir überhaupt nicht sicher ich
sage mal einfach laura und zwar 673.000
dass sie wieder richtig kalt jungle hat
auch weniger nämlich 22.000 wir sind
fertig noch mal über in diesen gleichen
versuch leute
was geht ab wie gut sind wir heute oder
wie gut bin ich heute also ich bin
normalerweise schlecht aber ihr wisst
was ich meine shutter island wird
definitiv öfter google hat 22.000 mal im
monat dann haben wir hier thora das ist
auch hu
ich dachte gerade die thora wir mehr
gegoogelt weil werde also wenn man was
daraus nachlesen also ich glaube ich wir
haben sagt ralf beachvolleyball
definitiv mehr als
warum h warum war das nicht richtig was
soll das ich hatte aber ich hatte 32 99
percent of people who play des gamescom
less than you that this game show
hatte einer von euch schon mal 32 in
diesem spiel heute einmal applaus für
mich wird das ist ein moment gerade in
meinem leben ich fühle mich gerade
wirklich so als hätte ich etwas
symbolisches etwas was wirklichen wert
bestand hat in meinem leben erreicht das
muss zelebriert werden freunde
das muss gefeiert werden zur feier des
tages stoße ich mit euch darauf an mit
wasser muss man sich ja auch mal gönnen
drei wochen später
ich bin immer noch begeistert von mir
das war es hier vom video meine damen
und herren könnten habe fast meine nase
gegen das mikrofon geschlagen wenn euch
dieses video hier gefallen hat würde ich
mich sehr über einen like freuen
schreibt mal in die kommentare google
wenn ihr jetzt noch dran seid
findet jetzt weil die blätter wieder
drauf den könnt ihr bei kanal abonnieren
da oben findet ihr auch meinen shop
eingeblendeter könnt ihr so sachen
kaufen wie beispielsweise dass sich um
euer handy besser festhalten uns
hinstellen zu können
darunter sind ein anderes video verlinkt
und da das video jetzt hier vorbei ist
können wir das ja mal anklicken ist auch
cool